[Music]
this is a story about the world's most
revered entertainment and Media company
about a revolution in Hollywood a
different landscape for players like
Disney who used to be the top dog
investors lost confidence in where
Disney was going bibiger has been one of
the most successful Chief Executives in
Hollywood history it's important to
think about Hollywood and Los Angeles
like a court
has always been a king Bob Iger was
certainly at the top of the tree it's
also a story of succession succession is
really important Disney clearly screwed
it up the first time around
now the king of Hollywood is back for a
second rant you're talking about a
different Hollywood a different
landscape for players like Disney and he
revive Disney is there a quick fix how
does Bob Iger reinvigorate Disney
[Music]
together
Disney's A company that doesn't really
need much introduction everyone knows
it's theme parks created by its founder
Walt Disney kind of embodies this
American Nostalgia it's this iconic
brand and I hate the word iconic but
it's true Disney is the largest Media
company in the world if you ask anyone
what is Disney or who is Mickey Mouse
they'll know before we talk about
streaming and all of the challenges we
should just remember what an enormous
entertainment Juggernaut Disney is it's
the most valuable entertainment company
in the world even after its stock prices
decline quite a bit it's got huge
Studios Fox television the ABC and ESPN
TV networks it's just a sprawling
Mammoth operation when Disney Rises the
industry Rises and vice versa the
question is who's the next Bob Iger the
answer that isn't immediately obvious
[Music]
it's important to think about Hollywood
in Los Angeles and the history of it as
a little bit like a court has always
been a king who the rest of the industry
sort of reveres might be a little bit
frightened of and looks up to over the
years Louis B Mayer Lou Wasserman who
created MCA Universal which is now
Universal Steven Spielberg David Geffen
Jeffrey katzenberg who formed DreamWorks
visual people who commanded a certain
amount of respect and a certain amount
of fealty Ira established himself as
somebody who could see where the
entertainment business was going he was
the the new king of Hollywood
Bob Iger is charming and Powerful the
guy that's having lunch with Oprah at
the Polo Lounge he's kind of embodied
that kind of Hollywood Swagger bobaika
has a pretty stellar reputation in
Corporate America a bit Jamie
diamond-esque the Pinnacle of the much
beloved American corporation comfortable
in a room with actresses and actors in
Hollywood but also politicians
and began at ESPN in 1999 through 2018.
I did work with Bob a different senior
level executive meetings one of the
great skills of Bob is being able to
read what the market trends are going
and make decisions on how to place big
bets he quickly set off on this series
of game-changing Acquisitions the
original Iger Reign at Disney was all
about content
when Bob Iger took over from Michael
Eisner in 2005 he came in and made some
very decisive moves it wasn't this
Behemoth that it is now Eiger really
built Disney through really big deals
and really big bets he made peace with
some of the most contentious
relationships that Michael Eisner had
had
Roy Disney made peace with Steve Jobs
which led to the acquisition of Pixar
Pixar was ironically started by a man
who learned his trade at Disney a guy
called John Lasseter he put John
Lasseter in charge of Disney Animation
the output improved immeasurably it was
hit after hit Pixar went to even greater
Heights they were able to maintain two
distinct cultures between the Pixar
culture in Northern California and
Burbank in Southern California animation
at the heart of the company was the
first thing he did the second big
acquisition was Marvel in 2009
buying Marvel was sort of a genius idea
and he took a bet Paramount looked at it
and passed Onyx they thought it was too
expensive ironically
this provided some of the biggest hits
in Hollywood history including the
Avengers series a member of writing at
the time good luck to them making money
out of some of these lesser known
characters or Guardians of the Galaxy
who's heard of that
and lo and behold there are these
billion dollar franchises built out of
these you know minor Marvel characters
like Guardians of the Galaxy
the third big transformative acquisition
came in 2012 when Iger acquired
lucasfilm from George Lucas the
lucasfilm acquisition felt like a pretty
chunky price at the time again this was
one where people thought maybe Disney
had overpaid
but this is really paid off with some of
the biggest grossing films in Hollywood
history not to mention all of the theme
park attractions all the films since and
all the series since it looked like the
deal of all time
the film Acquisitions that Bob Iger made
were brilliant each one of them seemed
very expensive but they all drove the
company's business in ways that no one
would have imagined at the time of
acquisition back in 2005 he wanted to
lean into technology in a way that would
exploit the opportunity for Content I
had the opportunity to see by sitting on
the campus the Vibrance of the creative
community that was on the studio lot uh
changed radically within a hundred days
he had taken a company of that size and
really redefined the culture within that
short amount of time a comic book
becomes a movie which becomes a video
game which becomes a theme park
attraction and so on in Pixar's case an
animated film that moves across so many
different businesses they are
leverageable across so many different
platforms existing ones and ones that we
haven't even seen created yet when Iger
came in the first time
Disney's content engine was not working
they were struggling in animation
when he left it was the strongest IP
content company in the entire world the
Bob Iger template was building
franchises within Disney that could be
used to power other parts of the
business a Marvel movie it's going to be
superheroes Pixar really great quality
animation nobody had that and because it
was branded consumers knew what they
were getting using that intellectual
property to drive sales of consumer
products to drive visits to the theme
park served Disney and served Eiger
really really well in the first 15 years
the top of the company Bob was
absolutely a very keen consumer of all
of our products his ability to be able
to think like a consumer and then act
like an executive was kind of felt in
his decision making the ultimate media
deal maker who made three of the best
Acquisitions in the history of this
industry the profits for Disney flowed
for many many years
Disney plus was Bob iger's big final
move in his previous tenure saying this
is about survival if we don't move to
streaming will become extinct
it grew very very quickly the stock
price was floating higher and higher and
higher as they kept adding more
subscribers there was definitely
mistakes made they bought a company
called Maker Studios that was a mistake
they bought Club Penguin 70 billion
dollar acquisition of the fox assets
from Rupert Murdoch at the time it was
seen as perhaps a pretty good
acquisition it's now viewed pretty
poorly particularly among activist
investors a lot of them think that
Disney overpaid for it outside of the
walls of Disney there seemed to be a lot
of discussion of Bob needing to find a
successor for the job that he had not
yet decided that he was going to vacate
figer was not just really good at the
job he also loved the job of running
Disney he extended his contract a number
of times the outside influence of that
conversation may have forced that
transition a little sooner than needed
to be
The Parlor game in Hollywood towards the
end of bobiger's first term was who was
going to succeed and this went on four
years people talked about Tom Staggs
Kevin Mayer Who are both seen as natural
heirs apparent Bob chapek a guy who ran
the Disney's Parks division was
eventually picked by Iger were very
optimistic about the future we're very
encouraged by what we've seen
unfortunately for Bob chapek one week
later the world shut down
foreign
[Music]
CEO of Disney was disastrous he had very
bad luck
he had to shut the company down
completely due to covet 19.
it seemed rather sudden that Iger left
was it fearing that the pandemic was
going to be worse than anyone expected
was it trying to go out on top I think
if there was any critique for Bob it was
the timing of the succession it's very
difficult to have a succession plan when
you happen to be enjoying your time and
succeeding exceptionally in your chair
you know it wasn't like chapic was made
president or CEO for a period of time it
was instantly transitioned to basically
becoming CEO it seemed like a rushed
transition he was always viewed as kind
of an outsider the satisfaction scores
that we're getting from our guests are
extraordinarily High he'd spent most of
his time working in the theme parks side
of the business considered more
operational yeah he wasn't a TV guy I
came out through TV used to be a TV
weatherman so I was really steeped in TV
and Hollywood culture
he was you know the guy at all the
premieres that everyone loved and I
think his biggest strength is the soft
skills convincing both investors and
actresses that this is the right thing
for them that was chapex downfall he
didn't know how to really schmooze with
people he lacked iga's tactility for
dealing with people with big egos for
dealing with other powerful people we
all know that Bob Iger had left very big
shoes to fill up tape just has a
different personality and so one of the
first things that happened publicly was
a big fight with one of their big stars
Scarlett Johansson Disney was going to
release the film Black Widow on Disney
Plus on the same day as it was released
in theaters the money that big movie
stars receive when they have a big
theatrical release wasn't going to
happen and this caused Scarlett
Johansson to ultimately sue the company
it became a very public quite messy
round I would never have done in a
million years never
when the agents start talking about you
and when the talent is crossed with you
then it's there's only really one way
down Bob Iger was the king of keeping
high-profile Stars their agents
directors all the people who are
essential happy there was no one better
then you have this culture war in
Florida with the governor Ron Santos
we've also drawn a very firm Line in the
Sand against imposing things like gender
ideology in our schools my job is not to
kowtow to some woke Corporation in
Burbank California a lot of the Disney
shareholders felt that it had been I Go
Disney wouldn't have been caught up in
this negative media storm at the same
time that there were a couple you know
public issues there were issues within
the company the company was restructured
a lot of the decision making went became
centralized creativity content wasn't
really his background the lifeblood of
Disney
is its creative output
and if the head of the company doesn't
have the support of the creatives then
you don't have a company
Bob chapek story is also one of A Series
of Unfortunate Events the pandemic
people are going to Cinemas people
aren't going to your Disney Parks but I
really do think the number one issue is
you're following Bob Iger you're talking
about one of the most successful CEOs of
all time Chipotle was replacing someone
who was more really than just a CEO and
he was still there in the town he kept
his relationships he kept talking to
people Iger set it up that way he would
stay on at the company have this kind of
creative role for a few years even once
jpac was CEO this God in in Hollywood is
sitting right behind you being like are
you sure what you're doing is right that
makes it difficult to be successful I
met Bob Iger just weeks before he was
due to leave the company at the premiere
of Encanto and Iger and I were chit
chatting and he said are you here to
interview him and I said yeah and he
said okay
it was an interesting moment there was
already a lot of tension between the two
men and they were barely on speaking
terms by the time Iger left the company
and then he finally did leave
um so tape had you know less than a year
where he was truly the one fully in
power
chapex
time was so bad there's like conspiracy
theories that Iger purposely chose
someone that wasn't that good just to
make himself look better right
Bob Iger is the classic CEO who has a
huge successful run it's difficult to
let go of that there is some magic to
being the CEO of Disney it's great to be
the king of the Magic Kingdom because
inability to pick a successor is
probably the big black mark on his
resume was chapik always the wrong guy
he didn't have the management skill
to build a team where everyone was
rowing in the right direction well sign
up for debate is that I could come back
and asked to clean up the mess even
after years of rumors everyone was kind
of shocked by it it was a Sunday night
when they sent out this email it's a
short statement iger's return to CEO
the final straw for Bob chapek was they
lost a billion and a half dollars in
streaming because they were investing so
heavily in the business that weekend he
was out Bob Iger came back to a company
that is significantly more challenged
than when he left there are macro
headwinds there are secular headwinds
disruptions from Outsiders Nelson Peltz
is this investor with his hedge fund
which is called Tryon his goal is to
raise the stock price and he makes money
off of it pellets put iron Under
Pressure to slash cost he wanted Disney
to raise the dividend to give him a seat
on the board a proxy battle is when a
activist investor takes a position in a
company and they want to board seat and
the company says no thank you
you can then choose to walk away or you
can do what Nelson Pell said in this
case and say I am going to ask
shareholders to put me in the board even
though the company has declined to do so
just months earlier Disney had given a
board seat requested by another activist
investor named Dan Loeb they were not
going to give another activist investor
a board seat usually proxy battles get
pretty brutal and they cost a lot of
money definitely tarnish iger's return
this billionaire investor was going up
against you know the king of Hollywood
and challenging it it was a personal
story why Nelson Peltz got into it
involving Ike paulmutter who was the
Marvel chairman he was on the inside of
Disney but he's very good friends with
Nelson pells and then Nelson pells takes
a stake and then Ike gets fired
this is the things that Bob Iger can do
that jpeg would never get away with if
you cross him you will pay for it it was
always going to be an uphill struggle
for pelts to wound IGA and ultimately he
didn't cost cuts and reducing staff
is not exactly unique to the Walt Disney
Company we've seen it at Paramount
Warner Brothers Discovery Netflix my
guess is Disney would have done a lot of
this stuff regardless but the fact that
an activist investor had the temerity to
take on Baba take on Disney this
household name shows you
that the shine had come off the Eiger
Premiership a little bit and that the
new reality he's confronting
is different and more challenging than
others he's had to deal with in the past
it's a more sober start to his tenure
and the agreement was that he would do
the job for two years and then he's out
but Logan now is dealing with the
biggest test of his career
[Music]
Disney about the farm on streaming so
there are three parts to Disney's
streaming business Disney plus a smaller
service called Hulu and finally there's
ESPN plus pandemic was actually a boost
for streaming services we're all at home
most people are subscribing to
everything Netflix and Disney and Hulu
because there's nothing else for you to
do about a year ago the economy changed
quite dramatically Rising interest rates
stock market's starting to fall
Disney share price has fallen off a
cliff it's about half of what it was
worth at its peak in the pandemic in
2021 investors changed their mind on
streaming Disney was one of these
companies that was losing a lot of money
streaming is a very very cost intensive
business that doesn't necessarily come
to fruition in two three four five years
so they went from you know cheering on
this strategy gross subscribers who
cares about the money into you need to
figure out how to make money
Iger in February unveiled his plan for
what he's going to do there's a big
focus on driving revenue and cutting
costs 7 000 jobs will be caught and five
and a half billion dollars in costs the
problem with this the streaming war is
that we're all a bit impatient right you
want to see something new every week on
Netflix so they're all being pressured
to continue to you know bring us all
these new shows we're starting to see
what a profitable streaming service
looks like some advertising
and we're also starting to see higher
subscription fees you can see that being
the the model that others in like Disney
Embrace an ad supported tier as well as
a subscription tier as linear TV erodes
and as the cable Universe declines the
opportunity for taking that advertising
to streaming has still not been realized
this is premium video you know if you're
an Advertiser the quality of the video
that you'll be in it's this is not like
user generated content it's where the
world is going and these these are very
high quality hard to reach demographics
Disney now has first party data their
customer is not subscribing to Comcast
which owns that first party data they're
now getting it directly and from that
becomes the opportunity to create new
ways to Target in the advertising
Community because they will know
families they will know households the
assumption is that people are not going
to want to pay for more than two or
three services when the dust settles on
this whole thing and so everyone is kind
of jockeying to make sure that they are
one of those three services there is too
much competition in streaming there's
definitely too many companies that are
going to require consolidation I don't
think there's anyone out there though
who doesn't believe Disney is an
ultimate winner
the question is what do they want to win
[Music]
goodness
is their goal to topple Netflix and be
1-2 with Netflix in order to be Netflix
you need not just kids and family and
franchises but you need reality TV and
you need movies and you need Thrillers
and documentaries how long are they
willing to lose money losses ballooned
up to four billion dollars a year under
chapic is Disney's Special Sauce really
just core Disney kids features animation
Disney is now an impossible situation
where they're trying to navigate the
existential decline of the businesses
that actually make money for them while
also trying to build these streaming
services that are losing billions of
dollars a year you've got companies like
apple and Amazon who don't care how much
money they lose in streaming and you're
competing against them cord cutting
meaning getting rid of your cable or
satellite system is accelerating
viewership of linear TV is declining
competition for streaming services is
intense and investors don't want Disney
losing three to four billion dollars
they want them making money in streaming
the new businesses
are not making money and it's unclear if
they will ever make as much money as the
old ones do and I think that was the
realization that investors really had
over the past year
Disney enjoyed one of the greatest
businesses ever invented in the last 40
years and that was the cable television
business a business where you get paid
regardless of whether somebody watches
just for having access you get paid
Disney's traditional TV channels have
been the biggest Money Maker but that's
the pass you can't go into streaming and
think you you're going to have what you
used to have you've got to realize it's
a substantially worse business but it's
better than no business but even with
ESPN they know that eventually they're
gonna have to move it to streaming
somehow and that's going to cost a lot
of money ESPN for a long time was the
Cash Cow for Disney and now because of
cord cutting it's in Decline like a lot
of the other cable channels in Disney's
portfolio and across the industry how
important is it for Disney to continue
to own ESPN they're starting to separate
it out financially is it a Prelude to a
sale there's a lot of questions around
ESPN that are affecting the stock price
Sports in the U.S is primarily built to
be able to allow advertising within that
the consumer is willing to not only pay
for the service for the right for sport
but then within that pay for the service
of right for sport to be able to have a
TV timeout why would that be a business
that you'd want to think about being
able to take away
I would not be surprised in 10 or 20
years if there's still a strong
steady broadcasting a Cable business
that contributes a lot to cash flow not
a growth business but radio has been
around for
I don't know 100 years and you know it's
it's not a growth business but it's it's
a big cash business among the numerous
challenges that Eiger faces and the most
important one is what do you do about
the theatrical experience what do you do
about the cinema
[Music]
is one of the few sectors that has had a
hard time recovering from the pandemic
and it's largely because people are
consuming entertainment in different
ways in the old days a Hollywood studio
like Disney would launch its movie in
theaters with a blizzard of marketing
adverts on buses on TV in the pandemic a
lot of that got jumped so that studio is
like Disney and Warner Brothers just
through movies that cost 100 million 150
million dollars onto streaming services
the economics of that don't work this is
why for companies traditional companies
that have other assets it's very
important to have the theatrical window
it sets the value not just for the
streaming platforms but for other areas
including consumer products his model of
franchises and movies which spawn
sequels is still successful but if there
are a few people going to the theater
that puts that model into some Jeopardy
the complaint for a while in Hollywood
has been that no one has any new ideas
and we're just regurgitating the same
franchises with different spin-offs this
is part of Bob iger's big mission how to
revive some of its great franchises from
Pixar to Marvel to Lucas the creative
content has to get better I mean there
is a view of of investors who are
increasingly worried when you see the
animation Crown sort of shift from
Disney to Universal
Super Mario is blowing Global numbers
out Disney is struggling I mean look at
light year last year they probably
didn't make any money on the film at all
Pixar has gone downhill not having you
know a Smash Hit in a while the
challenge is to figure out
how to do more with less bringing the
creative back into that conversation
gives you a sign of how Iger is
re-prioritizing the creatives within the
company he has a good relationship with
most of the big you know the heads of
the studios The Hope right now is that
he will be able to kind of revive those
engines even with less money
[Music]
all of the headaches that Disney's had
the great news that they've had over the
last year has been the rebound in theme
parks the parks business struggled
during the pandemic because they had to
close coming out of covet it almost
seems insatiable this demands for life
experiences in a post-pandemic world
even with limited disposable income even
with recession Parks have never been
more vibrant they've made more money by
raising prices which is something that
they've also gotten some backlash over
the idea that you know this is becoming
a luxury good when it's supposed to be
you know for
working class families one Wall Street
analyst I talked to said they could even
charge more and the parts would still be
full
the clock is running on Iger he's got
less than two years now to execute a
turnaround plan come up with a growth
plan
he's liking the man to revive dizzy I
wouldn't bet against him he has a better
feel for the company and a sense of what
it is than anybody else
it's hard to imagine anyone more
qualified there's no one better skilled
in Reviving Disney's creative Direction
and figuring out what the asset mix is
ultimately going to be the other thing
that that Iger has to do is to find the
next Bob Iger he screwed up succession I
have to believe he's not going to make
the same mistake to us what does Bob
Iger have that makes him so successful
why can't they find that within Disney
other people could have bought some of
these assets and didn't he was just
incredibly Savvy in his deal making
everything flowed through him almost to
his detriment right because now we're
seeing without him the company is unable
to succeed what most shareholders
believe is that IGA will try and stay
longer it's tough when you have that
much power and that much influence to
really let go of it that's a drug having
all that power who's the next Bob Iger
the couple of names being kicked around
but they're all going to struggle
they're all going to labor in the shadow
of this guy who turned the company took
it from here to here what they've done
now is created this perception that the
only person who can save Disney is Bob
Iger so what does that do when you
replace babiger it sends the share price
down if he turns the company around and
the share price goes back up and
shareholders are happy why should he
leave Iger has loved being the CEO of
Disney he loves being the king of
Hollywood it's great to be Bob Iger but
he's older let's face it the job's not
as fun now as it was before it's more
fun to be a swashbuckling deal maker to
make a deal with Steve Jobs to buy Pixar
that's fun Legacy building stuff
figuring out how to manage the decline
of the Cable business build out the
streaming business that's tough is that
what you want to do as you near your mid
70s I'm not sure we have the oldest
president who is running for reelection
I've got to imagine that in Bob's mind
he's a youngster in comparison to that
with a lot left to give
[Music]
thank you